thank you
[Music]
we're taking it back to the Army Navy
Academy because we have Mr Jason Cheney
here today for our off the Record hey
yes sir yes sir yes sir yes sir yes sir
the captain like Captain you guys really
had to do that all the time yes sir yeah
yes sir yes sir yes sir you you have to
salute the sun is in your eyes this is
hell
what was that hail Hydra what about if
it's one arm how do you do that one arm
what if you go like this is that you go
yes sir yes sir you actually do have to
salute like the officers or other kids
how do you do it this when you walk by
you you it's just this yeah and it's
like it's even the ones you're beefing
with yeah like on in the middle of the
school yeah like let's say you're a
sophomore and that guy's a senior and
he's an officer you have to when you
walk by you have to how do you know how
do you know someone's like by their
ranking oh how do you do it if you're
like passive aggressive with somebody do
you like a do you do a face or do you
yeah how do you do the [ __ ] one the
face yeah do you do it with like where
you're like like the like the real one
like the real one if you're gonna [ __ ]
them up later yeah yeah in public it's
just like this and later on is beat
their ass so there's no variations you
guys don't do so this is never affected
Jason have you ever gone to a fight or
did you just get beat up I got beat up
mostly I got beat up honestly so welcome
back to part two we had so much
information to cover because these two
like Bart so eloquently put in the last
video have been a part of something so
unique the amount of people that go to
boarding school in your life to the
amount of people that are Asian
specifically that beat up at this
boarding school the amount of people
that specifically get beat up that are
Asian at this boarding school that do
YouTube and we have 100 of that
population in this room
so we have to recount more of these
Amazing Stories and stuff like that so
now now we can bring it back go to the
um whether you were fighting and how
often did you get beat up a month well
the thing not because the frequency of
feet that these things happen like you
know when most people they talk about
fights and stuff in high school yeah
they're talking about I'm gonna fight a
junior year I gotta fight senior or this
thing happened here I stole the car uh
my sophomore year like the [ __ ] that the
frequency that goes down at these
military schools like I've been in like
three or four fights in one day before
so one day so you were in three or four
fights in one day were you in three or
four beatings in one day because then I
think we can corroborate the stories
more better cheers oh no no
um well the thing is I was there when I
was younger it was like eighth eighth
grade so there's eighth graders there
yeah eight to twelve oh it starts at
eight yeah it starts at eight so eight
is like super young but uh um but when
you say beat up sometimes in the
beginning more but
um getting hit all the time like like
the seniors will come with their ring
because they have the senior ring and
they'll just like they'll turn it around
and then smack you on the head
all the time like everybody they'll just
and it hurt they did it they didn't do
it like oh they like it's going all the
way back to make sure and then we'll
have like boots and then they'll come
they'll you know because then the
because we'll have to go to um I forgot
all the things but you gotta go to
formation and then they just come and
they're like stay in formation is
attention and then they'll you every day
Thiago this guy he will come with their
oh [ __ ] you were there when Thiago was
there yeah the ball boss dude he was
buffed here he's bald at his [ __ ] oh
wait what okay I know I think he was uh
he was a junior and I was there and all
two thiagos in the world also at this
Academy he's black he's not a Hispanic
guy no he almost sounds like he's
Brazilian yeah Brazilian or but his face
is black
was he a Golden Gloves champion in
boxing no I don't think so okay never
mind this is Thiago two what if that's
like a common ass name and then we just
think yeah yeah maybe it was just
Santiago dude I know it's also crazy I
was like wait there's two Regulators at
the school that are both called Thiago
wow exactly is that the prerequisite are
you a Thiago okay you're the next one
it's for sure the same dude bro what do
you know what Chang like he became
there's seven thousand chains there's
only two thiagos though I love it one
Asian guy telling another how many
changes there are in the world okay
what's Chang he's like what does it look
like he was like I want to switch seats
with butter I think it was Taiwanese
yeah because the editor is going to go
crazy editing this back and forth so
much work for the editor
that's so nice that you thought about
that talk to this look him in the eye
all right Thiago did he exist so he was
black in your eyes wow you're so close
in your eyes
was he black was he his back he was well
the thing he's black I think the biggest
he's black I think you guys are both
right dude it's for sure there are black
Hispanics but he either spoke Spanish or
Brazilian Portuguese did you probably
spoke Portuguese okay he spoke another
person okay so the question was how
frequently did you get beat up or get
into scuffles or oh you were talking
about you were talking about boots and
being in formation and then Thiago came
up yeah boots for Budget because he
would just every day he was my uh
platoon sergeant and he would just come
and do the ring thing and kick me in the
shin oh all the time was it just you but
getting beat up like getting jumped uh
only I you know that was after but
getting
I got beat up
maybe like
five six times but never getting jumped
by multiple people in total yeah in
total it wasn't that bad but
um
but yeah how about 101 fights when you
say beat up versus jump does that mean
you just got in a fight but you lost
yeah okay I'm just trying well to me
jump is like multiple but yeah more than
one person so I I didn't get jumped till
later
when I when I'm out of that school how
about how about one-on-one fight we
gotta get to that but what about what
I'm gonna fight like a couple like yeah
over nothing do they all challenge you
because I don't picture you no I did at
first so wait what challenge people yeah
I challenge you so this is the thing so
this is the very first fight I got into
it ended quickly oh so this is the thing
um sorry I have allergies but I I was
this was I was in U.S history class in
eighth grade thank you you need Zyrtec I
do but right now I'm gonna take a tissue
yeah because
I don't have a tissue
I gotta suck at it okay suck at it okay
but so what happened was
um I I was in eighth grade U.S history
class and uh uh there was a Korean guy
and he got held back like two three
years because you remember earlier you
were talking about yeah another episode
yeah it's really common to find a 20
year old seniors 17 year old freshmen
it's crazy yeah crazy school he was the
oldest guy in eighth grade and you know
he was like maybe 16 17 maybe
right it's the craziest thing he was the
biggest guy like
he was the
um biggest guy in the [ __ ] thank you
so much it's like it's like Community
College where you have a senior citizen
sitting in your [ __ ] economics yeah
it's like Community College where it's
like different ages the worst
delinquents ever right so you guys have
to remember that I did not know the
Korean culture or any American culture
at that point yeah so and I was the I
was the [ __ ] around in class guys do you
know did you know English a little bit
because you know you learned English and
I would know enough to be like you know
say something your stomach is fat in to
the teachers oh [ __ ] because I like to
mess around because I was never good in
school and then I'll mess around and
have a good time I just always want to
have a good time and um I remember this
Korean guy sang bomb he's like he he was
the oldest and big the the 17 year old
eighth grader yeah yeah
he was really big and uh he's well he's
like big he's like just naturally big
yeah and he wasn't fat he's just a big
guy yeah he was a super muscular but he
was just big yeah and um
I keep on saying stuff in class with
this other kid and then he's like hey
shut the [ __ ] up right he said that I
was like man you shut the [ __ ] up like
to him because I didn't know Korean
culture he and then he looked at me you
know how Korean people when they get mad
they always lick their lips they're like
he did this
okay no no he didn't do that yeah yeah
he did that when he was like really
angry he's trying to hold him yeah he
tried to hold in his anger and then he's
like okay after school let's go fight I
was like yeah let's go find you [ __ ]
ass big [ __ ] are you [ __ ] dumbass
instead he was just gonna be like let's
go fight and then after it was just like
ah I'm just kidding yeah to place a
context at this school like he's not
Chinese you don't even know you don't
even need words
like at this school like like if some
[ __ ] happens like let's say me and Nick
or me and like Ryan had had something
all we have to do is look at each other
and we know later on on site it's either
me or him or him or me uh you don't even
have to trade meet you at the lockers
meet you at whatever we just we look at
it and we already know [ __ ] 9pm comes
around on site six people on one or six
people on one it's just just gonna
happen yeah yeah but keep going it was
mine wasn't like this but it was super
casual he was just like okay after and
then after class he literally is like oh
let's go and I was like okay and then I
didn't think it was for real oh and then
he took me the whole time you were like
in disbelief like it's not gonna be that
because we're gonna go and then we're
gonna go where are we going oh we're
gonna go at the back of Queen hall and
then nobody was there it's just super
casual or just Queen them all again
Queen Hall it was like one of the dorms
oh okay yeah and then just behind so
that the teachers don't come yeah and
then he just starved oh wailing on it he
started but he's like take off your belt
I was like let's just go you [ __ ]
like that oh and then [ __ ] he just beat
the [ __ ] out of me I was on the ground
like okay no I know now
I know you are serious
I was trying to punch him I'll try to
watch him yeah and I would try to punch
him like straight yeah it's okay let me
tell you something when you try to find
a guy I don't know
because I try to fight him twice the
first time so the first time I would try
to punch him I I think my arm was too
his punches I just feel like his fist is
bigger than mine and he's just punched
through my arm onto my face
like you guys are just trading but
you're the one
yeah but and I'm not and I wasn't I
didn't I didn't have training I didn't
know what the fighting was
and I was just trying to go and then he
fought before for sure
I was watching me I was like he's got
experience this guy's good you got a
real future in this this is not his
first face where you don't understand
how you're getting hit you're just like
what yeah and then I went on about and
he was like still punched me and I was
like okay and then he's like okay so
[ __ ] don't you know what I mean
whatever the thing is I was like all
right I know now
ever so what happened the second time so
the second time we just did Body Shop
body shots because but why'd you even
agree to it if you knew what's gonna
happen no I thought I could maybe beat
him
yeah the second
though why did you guys experience yeah
how did the second time because that was
like
um I figured you it was the second time
during the same time no no no no another
time maybe like a couple weeks later
you're like if you want revenge yeah I
was like well let's go let's go then
let's go how did you do just body shots
because I was like let's just do body
shots so we don't get we don't see the
things so we don't get because oh so you
don't get in trouble they have to tell
you to go to the wall for like four
hours like your nose has a touch of
water for like four hours and it's
annoying and you get the merits and you
can't go outside yeah you can't leave
them but use campus on the weekend and
you have to sneak in the Casual yes it
sounds like prison for real yeah dude
yeah like if you get their match like he
was saying like on the weekend the good
kids they get to take the train or the
plane or ever go home on the weekends uh
if you have the merits Like Me Maybe you
did I never got to go out yeah
there's this [ __ ] square that they
like taped or painted on the ground and
you're just marching that [ __ ] for hours
the whole [ __ ] day I marched every
day dude you're just constantly like in
this [ __ ] line like this it's the
same [ __ ] it's that small it's like
the same no it's like maybe the small in
this office and it's just repetitive
over and over and over and over yeah but
I was like [ __ ] but that was I like that
though you like that I was just like
[ __ ] it because
they're so confused that are [ __ ]
around because another thing I didn't
like school huh what happened with that
body shots fight how did that yeah walk
us through that one well it's the same
thing oh exactly the same I was in
history Classics no no it was another
class it was I think I forgot exactly
what it was but I was like okay let's go
again then and then we're like okay
let's not have the face so that we don't
get and then after
um it's just he's so [ __ ] strong I
tried really hard but I last a little
bit longer but he just so strong and he
punched so [ __ ] hard and fast well
because it's probably 18 in eighth grade
yeah but then I was like okay I lost man
did you fall on the ground again no I
know now two times did you guys become
friends after that yeah we became
friends oh that's cool was that the big
Korean guy that you were talking about
the other story where you said there was
top Koreans so the was good at fighting
so there's two other Koreans and then it
was him but then yeah it was two other
Koreans that knows him and then the rest
of it so this guy's like ranked number
three ranked number I will say two yeah
because the other guy him and this other
guy was equals and then there's one okay
yeah so the two guys are a package deal
at the time yeah they're tandem yeah but
um
and then later on you talked about how
you got it so funny how did you get
jumped by a bunch of people oh that one
was um I was not in school that was that
was not in school it was my friend he's
trying to fight this other Chinese guy
this Korean guy he tried to fight a
Chinese guy not what do you mean not in
school this was out in public yeah it
was out in public oh like where like you
were at a bar like in Carlsbad no no no
this was outside of because he Joe was
asking to see if I got in a fight and I
was like no I only got jumped once by
multiple people by four people but
because of Fred was getting jumped they
were like okay one-on-one fight and then
they fought and my friend was winning
and I was like Yay
but where where was this it was like at
a mall at a mall yeah damn it wasn't it
was like outside of a mall it was like
behind a YMCA
and um at first it was just my friend
and but there was a bunch of people it
was like maybe seven eight people and
then it was me my friend and two other
guys and then it was just one-on-one and
then my friend was winning and then the
guy he just grabbed my friend's hair and
then hit him in the face and I was like
that's not fair another guy not the
one-on-one just another another guy and
I was like that's [ __ ] up and then
I jumped in and then they jumped to me
but then I was getting really [ __ ] up
how bad did you get [ __ ] up
um with I got cut and then my back hurt
because would you have osteoporosis
but if it wasn't because of me he would
have my friend would have gotten seven
guys on him and then also two of my
friends they just watched they didn't
help no a whole bunch of [ __ ] I was
so sad are you still friends with those
guys no the bystanders no what was this
did you did you get mad at them after I
don't I I was like really I wasn't mad
but I was like disappointed and I was
like how could you do you remember what
the what was the whole thing over what
was what were you guys fighting about so
it was them they got the AOL they got a
they were AOL yeah cotton [ __ ] and then
instant message fights gang huh yeah but
uh oh everyone was Asian in this whole
fight no so it was me my friend was
Asian and the other guy was Asian and uh
the rest of them was our meme oh no
Armenian or Middle Eastern and about
both of our friends was Asian too bad
they just watched
that's so sad that is very sad you don't
watch
you gotta jump in yeah so you sent me
some pictures we didn't go over last
time okay send me my phone this is over
an AOL fight all right so there's some
pictures you sent me from military
school days yeah but what did but you
went as a senior I would love to be that
I went in as a junior oh June yeah
Junior but you were as a senior because
you got held back one grade is it yeah
yeah yeah yeah
um but you get birthday punches too did
you punch people for the birthdays
uh oh yeah like yeah yeah yeah that's
like everyone though yeah everyone gets
birthday bunches and that's when you
find out the numbers are pretty high
because you're like wait why is that guy
getting 20 punches in high school that's
how you figure out people's ages because
sometimes you got to punch them yeah I
remember this one time I was in the in
the uh watching somebody else get a
birthday punch and I was like that
doesn't hurt that bad and then I was
laughing I was like your face you're
getting punch and then the Chipmunk the
guy the Japanese guy was like
um when's your birthday it was like so
at the time it would say it was like
March and then he's like when's your
birthday my point of me I was like
September and he's like okay we're gonna
get you right now though oh that's not
correct that was like what and then I
just gotta and you just have to take it
yeah but it was it was cool though do
you feel like all of those experiences
it sounds crazy Kim is it does it make
you a tougher person or do you like look
at fights differently or yeah so like
because I got contact was so often and
but they gave me cigarettes so I just
want to say that they gave me uh they
[ __ ] you up and go here's a sick right
here like thank you what is that uh
seven not seven star the other one
Benson and hedges no it's a Japanese
cigarette it was so good because they
had charcoal in it oh oh yeah I know
Seven Hills or something like that
[ __ ] it was mild sevens mild seven
I was smoking a thing anyways um but you
were saying that oh just like all the
fights that you got it as a as a
at a young age did it feel like it made
you tired because the thing is like you
get hit all the time like the contact
all the time and so when I went into the
public school I got in a fight on the
first day but not first that first week
oh uh because you started [ __ ] or no he
so the senior as a senior he would he
was like saying something to me and then
I was with my friend and he's like oh
he's talking [ __ ] and then but I got
beat up too is the thing
but I didn't mind
so you got beat up again at public
school yeah so it desensitized you but
but I I went up to him but that's
something because it's like something
you stood up to him yeah
he's like the bravest guy that he's
really good at taking a beating yeah so
you're not afraid of the beating no
because in all all of his stories it's
like there's no trauma it's just like
yeah I tried and I lost he's young
Captain America you know before he gets
the serum and he's just like I could do
this all day it's like keeps on going no
no no he's like Rocky on the first one
where he keeps getting his ass beat you
know but it wasn't like I could do this
all day I go okay can you stop now all
right that's enough
yeah but uh but yeah but because of that
um it was okay because at that school uh
everybody because he was a senior and he
was like a football player but um but
yeah I stood up to him and because of I
think because of a a because everybody
was getting and people were just getting
[ __ ] up you know yeah anyways time
yeah all the time so it was it was okay
what was the aftermath though after you
got beat up by this uh this guy who
nobody probably stepped up to him like
was it did you get any respect for that
yeah you get some respect no there's no
they're just like okay
inconsequential got it he got suspended
for getting beat up
man yeah but uh wow and you just totally
fine with all of it that's why he's the
man though yeah look at this guy this
guy's the man
no but uh but yeah but that's the thing
but I saw in the picture so in the
picture you said
um one of them you play football too
yeah I play football too oh at a yeah
yeah so I always like like locker room
stuff what does that mean
well like towel touching penises or like
so
yeah I like that I like because I always
when I was a kid I always watched like
military uh movies like at home and then
I'm like man I wouldn't I always would
just want to be one of the guys yeah
that's so cool yeah it is cool yeah just
[ __ ] around and stuff so during the
whole process you feel like you kind of
enjoyed the rough I loved it the
bullying the yeah that was the best did
you like it
I liked it a little bit too but I think
some of it went um
I feel like it's too much at a young age
you know what I mean yeah
where it's like where so at the amount
that we we got into it was like man it
was like sometimes it would be a couple
times a day where you get into fights
and stuff and he I think has more of
like a happy-go-lucky time and I also
think it was your approach when you went
to that school it was more like oh
America's a different place I'm just
being curious whatever the time that I
went I think I was probably carrying my
own baggage where like I already got
kicked out of maybe like I don't know
four or five schools yeah so when I got
there it was like okay [ __ ] it's my last
[ __ ] chance it's an expensive school
yeah so I was like okay my mom's
borrowing money from my uncle so you're
trying to be good yeah it's like 16 G's
for a semester for high school we still
got kicked out though I know so I so so
I was like okay
I'm gonna be a good boy I gotta be a
good boy here you know you still [ __ ]
up and then the first uh the orientation
of like all the new kids that come there
like they have new student orientation
right and when you're in that group like
like you come in and like everyone's
already kind of sizing each other up and
then like people like oh where are you
from and then you already know they're
hitting you up even though they're
trying to ask it in that way you're like
okay this guy's from my Dub C from
Frisco all these guys from over here
this guy's from 18th Street like you
just start you're like okay this is not
gonna be a a good scenario you know and
then so with that burden of me like it
please oh [ __ ] up please don't [ __ ] up
um you'll get challenged enough and then
so you end up fighting and then and then
like I was just never really good at
academic like there's some kids that are
really really good yeah like you're like
oh this guy's going to Harvard yeah so
it's so the the spectrum is so wide like
uh I remember so I've always been good
at math there's this kid he was like the
Russian [ __ ] Ambassador son or
something
and uh he saw that I got a really good
grade on one of our tests he comes to me
after school and he goes hey can I and
this is Russian accent because he grew
up in Russia he's like can I take you
out to eat and I would like to maybe you
can help tutor me and stuff so I was
like what the [ __ ] this is like the most
like professional diplomatic ninth
grader ever yeah exactly I'm like dude
the worlds are the Collision of Worlds
is [ __ ] crazy are you suspicious when
he asked you that a little bit but also
like I ain't going on a date fool that's
gay so we're guys like that getting beat
up too no no those guys are Untouchable
okay because on the parent-teacher
conference diplomatic immunity yeah when
parent-teacher conferences happen like
my mom's driving up in a [ __ ] CRV
this fool has like a limousine with
[ __ ] Russian flags at the front and
then his dad gets out with [ __ ]
bodyguards you know it's just you're
just like okay this guy's Untouchable
it's just so the kids didn't [ __ ] with
them because they because they know they
know right off the bat there's like
famous people like actor actresses son
that went there there's like so many and
then there would be like you said like I
didn't know what that was like dubsy and
then Viet boys yeah I think they had
that I think now that you said it
because I never experienced it as a
junior you know I think they had more of
that burden because they're like oh [ __ ]
I gotta like these people are are not
you know I mean I have to like they have
to represent I think you had that yeah
yeah yeah yeah oh it's like my yeah my
people I never had yeah so when I joined
I was like yeah like all these guys and
like all these delinquent Asians so in
the beginning okay I'm from the sgb and
I represent or whatever right and then
actually assimilate into the school I
was like oh [ __ ] this isn't really about
the Asians it's like little Asian kids
probably like this guy is getting
[ __ ] punked by like other races so
dudes that I was like on the street we
would be Rivals even though we're from
way different cities I'm like we're
actually gonna click up you know so like
me and this Asian boy's cat who maybe
would have fought over here we're gonna
click up to protect our so it's just
like a different like like world it is
like jail yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
it's just way way different that's
really nice
no no that that you that you felt uh
protecting you put your territorial
differences aside the ecosystem was like
that so you're like you can see how
things work so you're like okay for this
to survive because it's kind of you need
to do that because it's kind of like
you're now your property but you're like
you because they them [ __ ] with like
the Asian kids is like [ __ ] with your
[ __ ] with your [ __ ] yeah yeah then
you gotta yeah that's very nice yeah
it's not like that now look at all this
[ __ ] Asian hate that's happening when
the gangs disappeared so did the
protection yeah
laughs